good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast happy Thursday hope everyone's
having a blessed day thus far it is the
latter half of the week speaking of
blessings
here's one of mine jackiel
that's so sweet you know just how to
butter me up considering what you've
done I've done nothing I I know you've
done nothing like what what you've done
is technically standard procedure here
at the toes sometimes when one is
traveling we have to record the night
before which is not a big deal we did a
few times last week I just am broken
this evening I've been broken down and
when you we were not sure if we were
gonna record at night or in the morning
I was you know just hoping it would be
the morning and then you said it would
have to be tonight
and it just wasn't an ideal situation
for me now of course you have to do what
you have to do and we have to do what we
have to do and I will give the show
everything that I have Jackie just know
I'm suffering
oh you are you want to know why
um I think I know but I'm sure you want
to let everyone know why no you don't
even know this is like a new update in
my life oh
I ordered room service I got a sandwich
it came with chips now I know you think
that's like an acceptable substitute for
French fries but I'm just here to tell
you it's not
no I'm here to tell you that it is and
we were kind of talking about my
suffering I just want to let you know if
you're not alone in your suffering like
I'm hearing no I'm suffering too I kind
of feel like you just monopolized on my
suffering I was taking a moment to
complain about myself you know just I
was feeling like sharing my unhappiness
and you kind of took that from me well I
was more so just trying to relate to you
on like a suffering level
yeah yeah I don't see chips as
sufferance but you're so wrong about
that girl like you're so no you're so
wrong especially for a sandwich a
sandwich is arguably better with chip oh
my God that's such a lie that's so nice
no it's not no it's not like a fry is is
always good I'll never turn one down I
would literally have fries with pasta
but for a sandwich
no I'm team I'm team chip was it a
kettle chip let me show you I I didn't
even was it a ridge
it looks like you know homemade I really
it has a little bit of Personality yeah
and I don't really like chips like
period especially from a restaurant from
a bag totally different like love a chip
for a snack but a restaurant serving
chips it's like come on do more
well I don't feel sorry for you for that
but I know you've had a long travel day
um I know some things didn't go your way
this evening I don't know I don't want
to spoil it because I'm Vlogging but my
flight here was crazy I'm not gonna
spoil it though okay great I'm excited
to watch your Vlog we're just kind of
loving the adventures of turdy Lou I
know and like so far the Vlog has
literally just been me Margo hasn't
landed here in Dallas yet it's like 8
P.M she doesn't land for a little bit
she flew after work so it's kind of just
been The Adventures of like turdy being
lonely and like eating her way through
the airport and Frisco
The Adventures of turdy lonely
dirty lonely rebrandt
attorney Lonesome well I don't know if
you know this but usually your Vlogs are
mostly you so we're used to that like
even Nashville we got a whole lot of
dirty no I think they were laying on the
removal in the long
I think there are lots of other like
supplemental characters of course it's
it's our patreon like who should be the
star babe
I maybe honestly because of the prank
call maybe yeah well you know really
quick update from our show that aired on
Wednesday I did get in contact with one
of my teachers I totally forgot to tell
you she texted me the one you were
hoping to get in contact with no but I
welcomed a welcome to contact
nonetheless and it was so nice to be
reconnected so you know what it's all
good
also someone did comment on one of our
various media images from Wednesday's
episode that they know Miss sheinbein
that she was her teacher in Israel and
she's got the hook up oh my God she can
connect me with my shine bye yeah oh I
didn't see that comment or else I would
have literally responded immediately
yeah no I was in the comments because
yesterday's episode was just so funny I
just wanted to see if everyone was
chuckling along so honestly I think some
of our best work and we just rolled into
the office but it wasn't I don't even
know if it was our best work because
sometimes our funniness is like really
smart funny and just like
and I wouldn't say it was like on point
it was just
like ridiculous unhinged you know I
don't think it would be our most on
point comedy ever like it wasn't you
know yeah like a statement it wasn't on
point comedy we were just having a good
time sisterly like unhingedness
sisterly nonsense
yeah
um and I'm hoping you know to go round
two with with Jackie O and dirty
you might get some sisterly nonsense
because when we have the sisters after
dark it's always a different flavor yeah
that's so true nighttime recording we
are exhausted we are exhausted sisters
I'm a very I think patient person and I
do think like my patience is running low
tonight so who knows what we'll get was
rolly rolly acting out no no he was
great I don't know I well I did cook
dinner so I was on my feet for a while
and I guess that
that wasn't the best idea knowing I had
to podcast but I just today drained me
turning Marlo that's all you had to say
listen you're pregnant like you're
allowed to be tired like yeah
a lot of walking the cooking like I just
at eight o'clock I just kind of am like
done for the day and then Here Comes
turdy hey girl we actually have to
podcast tonight
yeah but I'm all set up and uh my
complaining is is done I'm gonna close
the book okay so officially it's over we
can't complain anymore I'm not going to
complain but I do I'm still like feeling
the way that I feel so I just feel like
turdy's not gonna get away with her
typical turdiness by the way that's how
I felt yesterday remember I told you I
was like feeling down at the beginning
of yesterday's episode and not yesterday
sorry Tuesday and the toast has healing
restorative properties and by the end of
it I was feeling great so maybe that'll
happen to you maybe you'll get a second
win maybe go for a run or something
yeah for sure right
right yeah no maybe I'll be like well
enough to read after this oh you know
I'm reading my book for book club the
one that Margo says is like literally I
love this book so much it's the best
thing that ever happened to me I love
this burger
right
it's things in which we left in the
mailbox
[Laughter]
it's called things we leave unfinished
and there is a mailbox on the cover and
so my book club chose it for their book
club because Margo's saying such high
praises and me and Margo have really
similar taste in book in books and she
was like you have to read it you have to
read it and I can't wait till she gets
here because I have to tell her how I'm
[__] hating this book like with my
entire soul like it was making me angry
on the plane that I had to read this
book I don't know how I'm gonna break it
to count I think she's gonna be so
devastated and I'm 40 in It's not
nothing like oh my God it's just
insufferably slow
well definitely Vlog you telling her oh
good idea
do like a hidden camera
you're on Candy Camera we can get to see
the real counts oh my God she like slaps
me I feel like people don't know the
real counts do you feel like they know
her
that's actually a really good question
like and I don't think it's because she
like obfuscates and and puts out a
version of herself that she's not but I
just feel like it's so hard to peel away
the layers and get to know the real
accounts that it's actually impossible
for people who haven't known her for 26
years to be able to I also think she's
extremely Dynamic like I don't even know
if I could pinpoint who the real satch
is you know like do we even know the
real Count I don't know I don't like
there's so many different versions of
her and she's still very young she's
coming into her own maybe she doesn't
even know the real counts
interesting yeah I think there's like a
couple different versions of her and
that we know them all but like I wonder
which one is the real her it's like
Kylie you know I feel like Kylie went
through a period like that when they
were filming Kardashians it was just who
is hashtag who is Kylie Jenner maybe
when you're vlogging you could ask Margo
be like by the way I just have a
question for you who's the real counts
no yeah she worked at nine to five got
on a four-hour flight and then it's
gonna come to the hotel and be like shut
the [__] up you annoying ugly [__] sit
her down like it's a confessional and
love is blind like on the bed yeah
and say people want to know who's the
real counts like is she really that
sweet little sis who just warms the
heart or is she like that big scary cool
girl fire or scared of fiery who we're
scared of who we're scared of
who which sister would you say you're
most afraid of
you I would say you too I think that's
that's good maybe it's because we work
together so there's like an added level
no I mean yes sure whatever like but no
it's you for sure why you know what
maybe I don't want to know
no
no I don't think you would be her but I
don't know if I could put it to words
when we were growing up we were all
afraid of Olivia but like as we should
have been she was like the scary older
one and she held all the power because
she was always in charge but I also feel
like we're all weirdly scared of Margot
now yeah because we just want her to
love and accept us
yeah but I actually feel like the argue
like we are all in some way scared of
Olivia we're all in some way scared of
you guys I feel like the intonation on
all like was a little unnecessary
[__] [__] I think we're all scared
of turkey yeah
I think you guys would say like you're
all scared of me all the time yeah
and we are all scared of Margo I think
that's good because fear really does
equal respect no yeah you need a healthy
combo of fear and love it's all about
striking the right balance which I think
that we've struck yeah also I was I feel
like I was having this conversation with
my like high school friends recently how
like we all grew up like afraid of our
parents and how like we're actually
grateful for that now and yeah it sounds
crazy like you're afraid of your parents
no but there was like a level of
authority and fear like the same way you
never want to be sent to the principal's
office like that's a good thing it keeps
you in check it needs to mean something
right like that level of authority yeah
just a conversation just loving with my
friends that I decided to share
yeah no I don't think that is a hot take
like I think that that is good parenting
to have both fear instill fear and love
in your children right right
because fear really that's in my
experience most of the time like equal
respect eventually
yeah
yeah you can't have all fear no you
can't have Love Without Fear either
otherwise you're just to walk all over
you do you think are you ever afraid of
your husband
I sometimes am not your husband mine
[Laughter]
like I don't
because like I I guess but like more so
in the way of like my imagination like
not anything that has actually happened
but like what I think Could Happen see
mine is like because Ben you know I get
away with a lot with Ben like I'm always
like being annoying whatever you're
worried he's gonna snap no no sometimes
he does like sometimes I take [__] too
far and then I get really afraid because
it's like it took this man a lot to get
to this point like I've officially taken
a duvar and then I'm afraid of him
because he has all the power you know
yeah but it's because he does something
that made you afraid or no no just
because like I guess yeah it's like
imagination it's imagination like is
this man about to [__] snap no but
like and I'm sure her husbands would
have the same answer like are they
afraid of us absolutely like they should
be absolutely they're afraid of us they
absolutely should be but I actually
don't think like you should be afraid of
your husband no no me neither because I
just but I do think husband's husbands
should be afraid of their wives gender
roles are real and like that's why I'm
personally not for like gender equality
because I would like my husband to be
afraid of me and I don't want to be
afraid of my husband 100 and that's just
pretty much my thesis on gender studies
and I think you've nailed the course
Turtle do you think they'd ever let me
teach a class on gender studies in any
sort of accredited University maybe
clown college but
um do I feel like clowns are actually
genderless
it's like an amazing point
they all wear the same kind of wig they
all wear the same makeup and they wear
the same outfits they're like these
silhouetteless jumpsuits yeah it's not
like like the girl clowns wear a dress
and the boy clowns wear a pant no
because you're 100 right clowns are
gender actually you couldn't teach there
either I couldn't teach at Clan College
clouds are genderless like I this is a
crazy Revelation for me
oh my God
so you learned something new every day
when you listen to the toast
yeah
um so we should dive in correct because
we have five stories
we do have five stories so one two three
four five right yeah it they it's one
less than six but one more than four
one lesson
lessons oh so five
oh my God you could say five is like you
really wanted to if you needed to put a
number to it right like if I if we're
putting labels on things like it would
be five
if we're putting labels on things it
would be the Fast Five
oh now they're fast oh okay
yeah they actually are pretty fast
they're not like crazy substantial
no no but I think they're gonna be a lot
of fun I like it a lot you didn't give
me enough time between yesterday's show
and Today's Show I know I know more
stories to have totally like nothing
crazy happens tonight that like by the
time our episode like would have come
out tomorrow like we could have done
like an hour-long episode like Kim
Kardashian get super secretly eloped or
something you know you know what that
never happens
um it just it does and the only thing
we're missing out on is not being able
to recap Vanderpump Rules sorry guys I I
take this one on the chin like I'm just
booked and busy and I'm so grateful to
be so booked and busy and and I'm sorry
next week is the finale so we'll have
our recap then oh wow I'm excited yeah
also so Random I saw Lala did like
another episode of her podcast you know
Bombshells but one of the Bombshells
that she spoke that came out was that
they actually have edited the final
episodes of this season unlike Andy said
yeah what I heard when I said that last
week was that Andy maintained that they
hadn't edited the next episode of inner
pump rules like right after Scandal
broke but they edited the season
um
so
okay that would make sense yeah it
wouldn't make sense whatever
semantics so now without further ado
here are the fast five stories that you
need to know
and I'm jazzed because today's lead
sponsor skims I'm wearing skims right
now Jackie I too am wearing skims right
now so if it's everybody collection the
Broadway me too so skims is the solution
oriented brand creating the next
generation of underwear loungewear and
shapewear for everybody so we've been
wearing skims for many years because
Jackie and I are breast experts we're
experts we're looking for bras all
different types of bras personally right
now I'm wearing what Ben likes to call
my relaxation bra but I need you know
t-shirt bras I need everyday bras and I
have to say the fits everybody
collection of underwear form-fitting
Essentials all of it is so fabulous
they're really size inclusive they go
from extra extra small to 4X they're
offered in nine core colorways and
limited edition seasonal colors I have
so many of the the relaxation bras that
I like are the racerback bralette that's
what I'm wearing right now I also love
the T-shirt bra like I have boob
problems I know Jackie like all
different faces of your boobs over the
last two years like you have turned to
skims for help is that correct yes I
have right now I'm in my size large fits
every bra fits everybody bralette era
because it's like my comfort bra but
also like my bra when I'm wearing a
sweatshirt and I don't want to be
wearing something with the clasp but
their bralettes are the best strapless
bras period like there is a bra for
every breast believe the hype this
collection is over 90 000 five-star
reviews for a reason skims fits
everybody and more best-selling
Essentials are available now at
skims.com plus get free shipping on
orders over 75 that is all at skims
skims.com today's episode is also
brought to you by better sleep we all
want to feel ready to conquer our day
when we wake up but when you've got a
lot in your mind it's tough to get the
rest that you need with the better sleep
app you can personalize a sleep
experience that calms your racing
thoughts and boosts concentration
Business Insider says that better sleep
is one of the most positively reviewed
apps in the history of the App Store so
it is basically your tool kit for
improved rest they have over 200
soothing sounds and a range of Smart
features to help you sleep faster deeper
and for longer you guys know I feel like
many years ago I was like very anti-like
sleep sounds and sleep stories but I'm a
Believer now the better sleep app has so
many different ones it's very personal
people like different things different
accents different stories you can
explore audio tracks from categories
like ASMR which I love I love listening
to ASMR before bed they have brain waves
meditation stories and more
it's an award-winning app that works
it's one of the most positively reviewed
apps in the App Store and it's backed by
Sleep Experts and it's backed by science
high quality rest is vital to mental
well-being and physical health better
sleep collaborated with the
world-renowned sleep specialists at
Oxford University and they are helping
you achieve your best sleep when you
sleep better you feel better improve
your quality of life in as little as one
week download better sleep from the app
store or Google play that's better sleep
b-e-t-t-e-r-s-l-e-e-p on the app store
or Google Play
thank you Claudia you're welcome Jackie
our first story some baby name news long
awaited the name of Rihanna and ASAP
Rocky's baby boy has finally been
revealed
are you ready have you heard it yet I
did
Rihanna and ASAP Rocky have reportedly
named their baby boy RZA athelston
Mayors according to Daily Mail their son
is seemingly named after the producer
and rapper RZA the leader of the Wu-Tang
Clan so I'm not sure if it's pronounced
RZA or Reza but they're all capital
letters so I'm inclined to say RZA oh
really I'm in Cloud I'm inclined to say
Rizza like sizza
scissor is SCA that was like my initial
Association but I'm not entirely sure
this is giving me I just feel like I
feel like it would be so me to say like
Rosa and then people be like jerky it's
RZA you know no of course that's like
Elon Musk like we were like trying to
pronounce it
little
like I'm like I'm overthinking it I also
feel like we will eventually learn like
what they're calling the baby similar to
how we found out like they were calling
Elon musk's baby x you know yeah baby X
or Angel remember they were calling him
Angel too
yeah no they call him baby x right so
maybe maybe Riz that's like actually
really cute
yeah really cute
I wonder why now they've released the
name it's just so interesting this new
trend of like celebrities not telling us
their baby names like for a really long
time
yeah like I thought it was just a
Kardashian thing but no
yeah I mean take all the time you need
it's hard to name people it's hard to
name people like maybe they're not
telling us because they're having a hard
time choosing yeah yeah it's also just
so interesting how like the the Genesis
of like celebrity baby announcements I
feel like the one I remember like from
growing up was when everybody wanted to
know Angelina and
uh Angelina and Brad Pitt's baby's name
and they like were on the cover of
people and it was like Shiloh and it was
like the biggest deal People magazine
cover and now they do it in like
Instagram and like Instagram stories
it's just so interesting how that's like
evolved
yeah I feel like somebody baby name that
always sticks out to me is Apple of
course like she broke the [__]
internet with that yeah she broke the
printing press yeah it was before the
internet like I remember literally where
that's actually such a good call because
I literally remember where I was when
someone was like apple and I was like
what I was like six I'm like that's not
a name that's not a name that's
literally what I said
no but it's actually a really cute name
it's also kind of crazy how her kids are
named Apple and Moses because Moses is
very traditional
and Apple is very new yeah but both
Moses and the Apple were and maybe she's
just like an Old Testament girl she does
have like a Jewish lineage Gwyneth
you think that Apple was an Ode to the
Garden of Eden
I mean Eden would have been more obvious
Eden and Moses but yeah it still could
be Eve maybe their next
um baby would have been like snake
no
yeah I guess I never realized like those
two names are like so polar opposite
yeah get you a girl who can do both but
then it's just weird how like
celebrities release baby names and it's
like so crazy to us and then over time
they just become names like North is a
name
yeah that's weird
it is but
you just get used to it right and then
like if somebody else like in my life
was like oh my baby's name is like Sam
I'm like oh so cute like it's a name now
oh so cute no I mean I guess like if
somebody knew like name their baby song
I'd be like okay that's like weird but
okay go off even it was just psalm's
birthday and they were singing happy
birthday to him and in the video like
people didn't know what to call him like
because I did they also call him like
Sam Sam and and like Sammy or I think
it's like Psalm saw me Sam Sammy and
when it was like happy birthday
dear everyone kind of like flustered it
was like a restaurant where we don't
know the person's name yeah I was giving
like Cold Stone Creamery energy that's a
good call but also I also think
everybody pronounces Psalm differently
like you kind of say the L I just heard
it psalm
but like I think it's psalm
yeah I don't say some I don't say that
word a lot in my life so I kind of just
go phonetically but I am a phonetic girl
yeah I guess you're right I'm hooked on
phonetics it's not a word we use it's a
Catholic word correct
no
it's a Christian Christian word I'm
sorry
um and is it what does it mean it means
like chapter and verse right yeah it's
like a pasok pasok yeah okay I was
thinking about like that's a testament
translation
yeah interesting yeah so I don't find
myself saying it but I do feel like
everybody says it differently which
makes it hard to like have it as your
name
yeah what do you think is Kim's best
or actually what do you think is the
Kardashian's best name
for the grandkids okay so we have North
Saint Chicago psalm
Mason Penelope and rain
stormaloo Air True dream don't forget
about dreaming and Tristan
I mean
try what's his name what did they name
him Topher Topher no they didn't trust
and Tristan no that's the father
well we just reported on it this week
what they named yeah it's uh it's Topher
Tatum Tatum I got stuck in OBX land
you know what maybe rain
yeah but you know what I feel like it
also depends on the nicknames because if
we're going by nicknames I think Shy is
so cute
but just names I actually love the name
Penelope
yeah so I guess we would say corny did
uh in our in our opinion the most
favorable and also Mason is such a
popular name now and when she named him
Mason it was like a pretty like new not
popular name so she's kind of ahead of
her time it's also so crazy like when
you think about the times like there was
such a long period of time in the
Kardashians where Courtney was the only
one who was a mom yeah because she got I
think she got pregnant on accident
but it was just like did she like she
did not expect to be pregnant they were
not trying
oh I don't remember like I think
remember they found out they found out
like Courtney and Chloe Take Miami or
whatever
yeah
that doesn't mean that they weren't
trying that they like
oh I guess that doesn't mean yeah
because she it's not like she wanted to
be married or anything so right right
hmm yeah
um what was the story
Rihanna and ASAP Rocky Ariza I guess
we'll just have to wait till like she
drops it in like an interview or a
podcast or something in terms of
pronunciation she should do a podcast we
would love to have her yeah we would but
she really should do any podcast like
armchair expert yeah Joe Rogan it's so
many years since like she's really been
very public and so much has happened in
her life
yeah I don't like and she hasn't been
very public like since podcasting has
been what it is like so you need a three
hour Rihanna interview so true oh also I
don't know if you've seen footage
Beyonce kicked off her Renaissance tour
I saw one video she looked unreal the
outfits are the craziest thing I've ever
seen in my life I've only seen one
outfit rainbow it was gorgeous what
rainbow
uh multi-colored multi-color yeah long
sleeve like mini dress yes same actually
I saw a few jumpsuits it looks like a
production like it looks major
that's sick I'm excited for everyone
who's going and everyone is like you
know gooped and gagged because in her
pre-show playlist like while people
filled in the stadiums there was Taylor
Swift so everyone was like what does it
mean
means nothing it means it's a good
[__] song and it's going to bring the
right energy to the stadium right and
she's like a really popular artist and
what do you play at like stadiums you
play popular music right
glad that we sorted that one
are you ready for our next story I
really truly am
y Cohen regrets not having Meghan Markle
as a Watch What Happens Live guest oh my
God totally so Andy revealed he regrets
not having Megan to Watch What Happens
live during her time on suits and before
she married Prince Harry she was perfect
for it perfect in his recently released
Book Daddy Diaries he explained that
Megan had pitched herself as a fan of
the Real Housewives of Orange County but
he had nixed her as a guest he said
looking back at the offer he made a huge
mistake he explained in his book that
the reason he passed on her offer was
that he always thought that suits looked
like some simulation of a TV show to him
like it was shot on tape and broadcast
in a vacuum agreed I just want to say
that is like a stunning analysis like of
I have a lot of people who don't watch
suits and never did like perceived the
show because it was on like USA which is
like a fake ass [__] Network and like
it weirdly had this cult following but
there was like nobody famous in it
that's actually so gorgeous and I didn't
realize Andy's book was out I'm like a
little annoyed that like these excerpts
are coming out because I'm gonna read
them but like this stories like this
make me want to read the book this this
is the type of [__] that like is perfect
for a celebrity Memoir Andy does Memoirs
really well
yeah so he said that he managed to make
amends with Megan when he was one of
three male guests on her podcast
archetype so I guess all's good there
but obviously like she's not going to
the clubhouse now or back in the day she
would have and I'm sure you know he
would have between the games and the
questions that they asked there would
have been some funny sound bites that
came from it that we could all look back
on now she's probably immensely grateful
that she was turned down and she would
literally like I think I don't think
there's actually a worse platform that
she could go on
because like she's very tight-lipped
there's like a lot going on with her
family and stuff and like Andy is just
out of control and the user and the
people come on you know the zoom like
ask questions directly to like it's
chaos somebody who has like so much
Scandal like and just like chatter and
gossip around them is not the right
person for watch Robin's live
no but I think that if she did it like
there would be certain things that Andy
would not ask about but in exchange for
her giving like a little tea and maybe
if she is a fan of some Housewives like
they would really just focus on like her
on housewives honestly I think it would
be really good for her to do something
like that and to do interviews that are
like less stiff than some of the stuff
that she typically gives us that's
actually a really good point it would be
definitely like a one-on-one very
similar to how like Jennifer Lawrence it
was like this big special and they just
basically brought out Jacks and like all
these Phantom girls people to like talk
to her right right it wasn't even so
much an interview but more like a super
fan 30 minute thing for Jennifer
Lawrence
and I feel like he could easily do that
with her yeah it's actually like a
really good call
I don't think it's out of the question I
wonder if they have any sort of um
actually they probably have like a
decent relationship because now that I
think about it I didn't know that Andy
was one of the few guests on her podcast
but there was like not a lot of she
doesn't like a lot of celebrity friends
that like we see her out and about with
so she tapped Andy to come on her
podcast like they obviously have a good
relationship that's like nothing I
didn't know that that's like kind of
crazy that was like Serena Williams
Mariah Carey Paris Hilton on the podcast
and like Andy
yeah but I mean you you remember like
the the Highlight guests but um I think
there were some random guests and that
was he was on with three people it was
him Trevor Noah and Judd Apatow oh wow
um
she had Candace Bushnell on
she had a lot Megan
had Candace
yeah she had Eliza Schlessinger with
Paris Hilton oh my God I missed like all
of this she had Jenny slate Constance Wu
H interesting so
it's they're not all Serena Williams no
that's a good point thank you I only
know that about her podcast like from
what was pulled in the Daily Mail and
page six and I never like went to go
listen so I didn't know that there was
like a such a big slate of celebs a
panel of three three guests yeah it's
like two to three guests per episode
interesting I didn't know that
yeah but and so
um really cool that he was on it but
he's exactly like who should be on it
he's using top of his game guy oh um
this actually makes me really excited
for Andy's book once I get through this
like dense ass book I'm currently
reading it is next on my list
great let us know what we need to know I
will let you know what you need to know
all right you need to know our next
story and you need to know that it's
brought to you by canva creating visual
content is an essential part of what we
do here at the toast but could the
creative process hasn't always been this
easy if you scroll down to our Instagram
and see some of the things we used to
like pass as Graphics you would be
ashamed and mortified but not in a while
since we discovered canva Ben actually
turned me on to canva he's choose it at
one of his old jobs ever since we found
Canada for teams it has been easy to
collaborate and design with our team
which makes the whole process so much
more fun and creative so canva for teams
is a design platform that makes it easy
for anyone to create stunning content in
any format from social media posts
videos presentations websites a lot of
people use canva like at their corporate
jobs for presentations we use it a lot
for social media content just to make
like professional looking Graphics the
endless templates and premium fonts
photos graphics and videos add a
personality and Edge to our content
canva for teams streamlines how we use
social media we can plan create share
social media content all directly to our
channels from one place and schedule
posts ahead of time which is such a
great feature it's just weekend gotta so
can't be bogged down by my Instagram
flow they enable you to take your
presentations it's a rhyme they enable
you to take your presentations you
should put that on a canva pro graphic
weekend's gotta go campy bogged down by
my Instagram flow obsessed it canva free
idea they enable you to take your
presentations to the next level plus the
remote control feature means you can
virtually connect and navigate slides
from any device collaborate with canva
for teams right now you can get a free
45-day extended trial when you go to
canva dot me slash toast that's
c-a-n-v-a dot m e slash toast for free
45 day extended trial canva dot me slash
toast today's episode is also brought to
you by the real real the largest and
most trusted source for authenticated
luxury resale we finally made it to
summer for all the events Beach weekends
weddings and everything in between our
go-to shopping destination is always the
realreal.com Jax and I are proud real
real customers for many years we're all
so proud consigners because you know you
want to invest in things you got to make
room in your closet you know it's a
cycle and that's how we keep the
environment sustainable cycle yes the
circle of life
you'll find everything from Gucci Prada
Hermes gani stodd so much more they're
all up to 90 off retail with 10 000 plus
new arrivals every single day you are
bound to find exactly what you are
looking for on the realreal.com I have
gotten some gems I've gotten some really
good like everyday pieces that I would
never like spend the retail price on and
then of course there are like some nice
things that I've like spent more money
on that I've waited a long time to get
and finally found on the real real it's
more sustainable it's more affordable
and it's the real real is just like
really trustworthy and if you want to
consign they have a full service
experience from free virtual
appointments and at home pickups to
direct shipping and drop-off Services
one of the easiest ways to shop or
consign is through the real real app so
download it now plus visit
therealreal.com use code toast at
checkout for 20 off that's a lot that's
the realreal.com code toast for 20 off
terms apply that's code toast
thank you Claudia you're welcome for all
the links and all the codes I will save
Jackie I can tell you're feeling much
better
are you no sometimes when I'm Delirious
oh yeah like I sing and I also like LARP
out like sometimes when I'm falling
asleep like I have to talk to Bruno and
like as I'm just YouTube
um usually Zach is there he's not a part
of it and it's like annoying he finds it
very annoying but I'll be like shots and
crafts and Lassie Madison would never
like I just have to keep going you also
have to get that out of your system
before you can actually sleep peacefully
you have to get that toxicity out of
your system no it'll just bug you it'll
keep you up you'll be up like thinking
why can't I sleep and it's because I
haven't larped
wrestling Stratton mass and crafts and
dancing last and fasten
Sam would never tell last sand he would
never tell a lie sand and that's the
damn truth and if he did I would cross
sand oh my God I would throw myself into
disgusting
isn't it fun makes me want to eat a
french fry sand
[Laughter]
some people count sheep other people
LARP
I think just you but it's good I think I
just turned you on to something 100 Ben
will never forgive you wait you wanna
hear the craziest thing I meant to tell
you
sure
I went through TSA on my way to Dallas
and they like were so suspicious of my
microphone
they were wiping it down and like
putting it in these machines like we
need to test we need to test for
explosives I'm like you're [__]
kidding me right literally it was I got
like pulled over thank God I was early
it's because this show is the bomb
[Laughter]
I was like ma'am the only thing I'm
guilty of is making sick podcast content
on that thing so like stop she did not
think I was funny and I could tell and I
was like it was she was like what is
this I'm like my travel mic like is
really weird looking so I'm like it's a
podcast microphone I have a podcast and
then I was gonna be like maybe you've
heard of it it's called The Toast but
she was like she'd been like she didn't
know ma'am she didn't want a LARP like
at all she was serious about her job
which I respect you know security is
important but like come on I respect
them taking it seriously but they could
have just like Googled the brand name on
your microphone and went on with their
day
no it's just like it's a microphone I
always feel bad when I see moms in um
security who are traveling with their
breast milk because they're always
[__] with people's breast milk like
they're like testing it and [__] and
it's like stop [__] touching that no
like get your dirty [__] mitts out of
there no literally like I've seen it a
few times and the moms get so upset it's
like don't [__] start with me do you
know like this is gold to me and they're
like opening it up like don't get your
dirty germs in there
that's disgusting yeah
yeah no they're really doing a great job
isn't it crazy to think about that TSA
is like a post-911 agency like before 9
11 like did you just Waltz onto planes I
don't remember
I guess so
we were alive but we were young
did you walk through like a metal
detector like what was life like pre-911
I don't know and that's why when you
watch like old rom-coms people just like
run through the airport like that
actually was possible back in the day
I don't know it doesn't seem likely you
still need a ticket yeah
are you ready for our next story yeah
Jamie Lee Curtis and Lindsay Lohan are
reflecting on Freaky Friday 20 years
later and giving an update about a
sequel so the two co-stars reunited for
an interview with the New York Times in
honor of the movie's 28 year anniversary
that's nice
it is nice they give you some really
sweet 28 20. okay I was like there's no
way I'm the same age as that movie
no no no no no it came out in 2003
directed by Mark Waters and also
starring Mark Harmon Chad Michael Murray
Harold Gould and more it saw mother and
daughter Tess and Anna switch bodies and
literally walk in each other's shoes so
Lindsay recalls as an 11 year old the
parent traps felt so big to me I threw
myself into everything accents green
screens playing to people so I felt
comfortable after that Freaky Friday
felt different because I was going
through all the faces of a 16 year old
but playing a character who was a year
younger she said this was the era of
Avril Lavigne and punk and I wanted to
experience it we did White Stripes in my
hair I put the color as Tracy cutting
them through hell because I took my nice
red hair and just bleached it Jamie Lee
Curtis recalled signing onto the world
days before she got to set after another
actress dropped out who who we need to
know I don't I'm gonna google it hold on
she said had I had all the Time in the
World to prepare I don't think it would
have been so good I just had to be in my
body I was also newly sober and I was
able to have a community within the
movie work world that was a big deal for
me
Annette Benning
I have to Google familiar yeah oh you
know this [__] like I can't tell you
what she's from but like she's a classic
she's from American Beauty death on the
Nile
yeah she would have been good too
I'm sorry no nobody could have done it
the way Jamie Lee did it was Perfection
and honestly her having like that pixie
cut was perfect
oh good call
uh let's call
no it's just like how Rachel McAdams
also could have done Deborah Wears Prada
but she couldn't have no but she
literally could have and it would have
been really great I know that's like not
the point of the article but I am hyper
fixating on the fact that like we almost
didn't get Jamie Lee Curtis in Freaky
Friday
yeah so they also shared some of their
fun memories and I guess they've like
stayed pretty close over the years
and they're both down for a sequel
they've been open about wanting to do a
sequel and
um nothing's happened yet but they've
been teasing that it's gonna happen you
know knowing what we know about Jamie
Lee Curtis from her recent stint on the
Real Housewives of Beverly Hills it
doesn't shock me that she's like stayed
in contact and probably like looked
after Lindsay Lohan a little bit over
the years because she really seems like
such a nice lady
yeah I totally agree it's not surprising
like just a queen who like looks out for
her fellow woman especially like a young
woman in the industry she was a young
woman in the industry you know she
started out very young and I I really
like I I love Jamie Lee Curtis like I
never thought I'd say that especially
because she's a pixie cut which is a
haircut I'm like totally against
yeah
I know that's really big of you
I'm growing up Jackie right in front of
your eyes Love is Blind next thing you
know I'm gonna have a pixie cut
you know I was listening to new Kelly
Clarkson so [__] good and like she
says in her song how love is blind and
she says it like in a negative way
meaning
Like Love is Blind she loved him so much
like she couldn't see him who for who he
really was and it just got me thinking
about this show because they came up
with like a whole like concept for a
show based on this idea Like Love is
Blind but maybe at the end of the day
like love is blind as I love being blind
is not a good thing like that lines you
there's different interpretations of it
and yes like
they're talking about like physical
appearance being blind to physical
appearance but what Kelly's talking
about is actually I think more a more
profound deep interpretation of the
phrase
blinded to a person's faults and how
they make you feel just because you just
love them so much blinded by love
yeah so like inadvertently Kelly just
like took down that show like um they
thought they were doing something over
there proving that love is blind as if
that's some good thing but they're just
being clowns gender fluid clowns her
power
her power nose no bounds like the way
she just kind of taken down an entire
franchise and she didn't even try that
wasn't even what she set out to do just
like one of the many collaterals
and all she said was Love is Blind she
just sang the title of the show and it
just made me see it differently
oh she didn't like explain herself she's
like trashing him and in the middle of
trashing him love is blind
Eternal Sunshine of the Spotless Mind
Jackie's version so unkind so good that
is very interesting
um I just want to say like on the record
while I loved Freaky Friday with all of
my heart and I was definitely very
influenced by it as a young girl I truly
don't need a sequel like I'm good unless
Lindsay lemon is gonna put that [__]
back in her hair and go to the House of
Blues and sing
that would just make me sad then I don't
want it
yeah no unless it's gonna be like just a
great movie that happens to be a secret
like if it's about like Lindsay Lohan's
daughter and they make the movie again
and it's just like so with the times
good product like if it is what for
these kids what it was for us so it's
Lindsay Lohan's daughter obviously Jamie
Lee Curtis is a grandma but then who
swaps Bonnie's
Lindsay and her daughter and Jamie Lee
tries to like Usher them through she is
also like a counselor right
I guess her job yes you know she was an
author yeah like a like an author but
she she was just written a book but yeah
I think she was like a psychotherapist
senescence
right so she should be able to Shepherd
those two through it that's actually a
good call and I want to say like
actually a fun fact they say you don't
learn anything from movies I only know
what the word senile and senescence
means because of that movie because when
she's reading she goes senescence like
senile oh oh and then she's on the talk
show like talking about being old I only
know the definition of that word I'm
sure I would have learned it eventually
but I was eight when the movie came out
and that's how I knew what it was
you were eight yeah because you said
it's 28 years old yeah no you said it's
20 and I'm 28. it's like young to be
watching like a movie [__] I think
about that all the time do you think I
think about that all the time that I and
maybe I didn't see it like the day it
came out but I definitely saw it like
the year it came out because we had it
on 100 I think about that all the time
because like how much older is Olivia
than me like four years
three years okay I guess that's like not
that old but like we were
but we've always been girls who like
we're at the center of pop culture and
like had our finger on the pulse of what
was going on and that meant watching
Degrassi when we were far too young for
it
yeah Degrassi tackled some really tough
topics but we knew that we were too
young for Degrassi I feel like so much
of the stuff that we watched at like was
age-appropriate like yeah we watched
until hand Freaky Friday and it's not
like there's anything inappropriate
about it it's just like we're eight
yeah like aren't you watching Barney
when you're eating like you're like
like a first grade
are you first grade when you're eight no
I think you're like third fourth grade
oh I don't [__] know see like I I
cannot conceptualize like kids and ages
yeah just like Elle King's son is for
when oh by the way he's one and a half
he's so cute
yeah and you laugh you'd think like now
in the last few years like watching K
grow up and like having frames of
reference okay before I like knew any
kids personally not being able to
identify how old a particular toddler is
I guess is kind of normal but I should
know now I'm like a very involved auntie
but all kids are different yeah some are
tall some are short is Harry tall
he's average no he's not
don't you dare he is so above average
that's so sweet I'll tell him you said
that you better I miss him so much
come back I am planning on it
great I'm not moving to Frisco don't
worry even though it's a lovely town
I've heard great things have you been to
Frisco
no I'm sure your husband has yeah yeah
it's it's you're like outside of Dallas
yeah it was like really quick from the
airport honestly
are you ready for our next story what
number is it four yeah so it's like not
the last one but also not the middle one
so when you say four
can you just dive into that a little bit
more
because I'm just feeling like unclear
yeah no so it would be like the one
after the third
not not
quite the fit though right so would you
it's before five yeah yes it's before
oh that's a good way to like remember it
that's a good way to remember it
okay okay our next story Imagine Dragons
performs at the Netflix picket line in
support of the writer's strike okay I
saw a meme I knew it was fake but it was
the funniest thing they're like really
smart idea for Netflix to send Imagine
Dragons to the writer strike so they all
leave and go back to work yeah I saw a
tweet that was like that's not fair of
you guys to subjects to Imagine Dragons
and it's like wait when did we all
decide that we don't like Imagine
Dragons I love Imagine Dragons it was
like a funny joke but I'm not gonna
subscribe like Imagine Dragons is
extremely talented that guy is very hot
he's allegedly dating Minka Kelly and
they have bangers like I'm not I'm not
I'm joking around like I'm not being
serious
yeah no like I just don't even know
where that joke would come from like no
people are acting like it's like
Nickelback
yeah and by the way like we could I
could have this conversation about
Nickelback like but and so I just don't
want I feel like when Nickelback was
kind of dragged through them I didn't
slandered and like defamed I was too
young to stand up for them and I didn't
have a platform I didn't have a voice
and I didn't know how to use it and now
that I'm of age like I'm not gonna let
this happen again to a perfectly lovely
band did you see that Lewis Capaldi
brought out the lead singer of
Nickelback on he's on like a big stadium
tour and sang like an acoustic version
of Rockstar and like everyone was
screaming the song at the top of their
lungs no I didn't know that and I'm not
surprised I [__] love Lewis Capaldi
so much like you know that I literally
he's like every year one of my top
artists I just like I absolutely love
his music and it doesn't surprise me
that he's doing King [__] no that's do I
look surprised no he should have been at
the car Nation though oh yeah yeah
hmm but he is currently on like a world
tour so that's like a good reason to not
be
yeah well the grammy-winning band took
to the Netflix picket line on Tuesday to
show its support for the writers
striking in LA in New York piano player
Dan Reynolds and electric guitarist
Daniel Wayne sermon
um performed radioactive and whatever it
takes the musicians joined a number of
celebrities who have hit striking
locations across both major cities to
show their support like Pete Davidson
who handed out pizzas in Brooklyn Ted
lasso writers and Stars Jason Sudeikis
Brett Goldstein and Brendan hunt Cynthia
Nixon Bowen Yang and Leno love Brett
Goldstein
to the strikers I also love Jay Leno
you do yeah I just like think he's cute
is that weird
that's really off brand isn't it because
I like hate like everyone in late night
yeah but he hasn't been in late night in
like 10 years
but he's kind of like the king of
lightning and sort of like the inventor
of all these people that you hate to me
he was like part of the last Great era
of like late night for a while was like
Peak comedy Johnny Carson what about
Letterman
he just flipped through the cracks as
like a towel attack I [__] hate
[__] hate Letterman like he's he
doesn't know it he's my Nemesis what
about Johnny Carson hate I mean what he
did to Joan yeah unforgivable I don't
care how funny or talented people claim
he was I don't support he's problematic
cancel don't meet everyone in late night
Sue hate everyone in late night
yeah I guess I guess I guess I do
I don't know there's some maybe honestly
it's because he's like chubby and cute
like I find him endearing and very
non-threatening a hundred percent it's
the chubbiness but what about James
Corden I do like him too
yeah again no I just like think about
people who have like actually made me
laugh and I feel like I've laughed at
Jay Leno and I've laughed at James
Corden and that's pretty much it
I've never laughed at Jay Leno but I I
don't think I've ever been like served
Jay Leno on a platter
I think there's something there I do I
do maybe this is just like no I think is
he like on Comedians and Cars and have a
good episode or something oh by the way
that might be it
yeah that would be a good reason what
the [__] happened to Comedians and Cars
Getting Coffee the Jerry Seinfeld
Netflix show that hasn't had a season
since 2019. they ran out of Comedians
and they ran out of cars they definitely
ran out of comedians because they were
double dipping with people who like
weren't that interesting and I'm glad
and they were like starting to show us
cars that I was like oh okay yeah cool
Subaru
like cool Volkswagen right
and they definitely ran out of comedians
honestly yeah there are people who have
been on it like more than once which is
just weird
yeah actually I feel like he could do
another season and have people who have
already been on because you know they're
Legends whatever but also there are a
lot of like constantly new up-and-coming
comedians like I'd rather see Tim Dillon
up there shaking that thing right like
Andrew Schultz there actually is like a
new generation of like podcast Instagram
patreon who like sell out huge arenas
yeah yeah
with Joe Rogan ever on it no
really yeah Comedians in Cars Getting
Coffee Joe okay
he should be on but he like Jerry like
never really ever like chose guests who
weren't like traditional comedy The
Comedy Club SNL writers room like that
trajectory which is like the very old
school way of becoming a comic like Open
Mic you know in the same three clubs he
never like dipped his toe into like
having and highlighting comedians who
came up through the digital age except
Miranda Sings was like the one time he
went digital and I think he said it was
because like his daughter loves her and
she did the whole thing in Like Her
Miranda character and like
it wasn't great
yeah I'm looking at the most recent
Seasons because I do feel like he had
some people who were not so traditional
but no even like
um it was very much like Ellen Steve
Harvey like that
he had Bridget Everett
I [__] love you should watch her HBO
show
what's it called I have heard it's very
good like someone somewhere
it's like her and her friend they live
in this like turnt small town and so
she's like a serious actress in it but
it's still very funny and I don't know
much about it but I know you like her
and I've actually heard it's quite good
okay cool
and I hear it's like on the verge of
getting canceled so if like you want to
start I think that'll pretty much put
the nail in the coffin
you know that's really funny I think
it's really like I thought you were
gonna say so if you guys want to start
and like support you know we could use
our platform but no you're right like if
I turn it on the next day it's gone yup
damn sad well are you ready for our
fifth and final story is it the fifth
and final story that's brought to you by
the perfect bar
it is because I need a snack after this
the original refrigerated protein bar
that you know and love for those of you
who live under a rock or who very rudely
skip through our ABS here are the past
five things that you need to know about
the perfect bar they're made with
freshly ground nut butter organic honey
and 20 organic superfoods they have 17
grams of protein and come in 10
delicious flavors plus a little snack
size bar too that are perfect for busy
toasters on the go they're made with
only whole food ingredients and they
contain no artificial preservatives they
are stored in the fridge and not to
mention they have the most sickening
cookie dough texture perfect bars truly
unlike any other protein bars out there
if we haven't convinced you already
they're also non-GMO they're gluten-free
they're soy free they're kosher they're
low GI and they're delicious you keep
them in the fridge because they're just
that fresh the ingredients need to be
refrigerated they're so delicious they
have so many different flavors and I
really like the small snack size ones
for
um just like throwing in your purse on
the go perfect Barn knows that it'll be
Love At First Bite so for a limited time
they're offering you a chance to try
their refrigerated protein bars excuse
me for free here's how it works sign up
for email or text and upload a picture
of your receipt from your local grocery
store and they'll reimburse you for the
cost of one bar it'll go directly into
your venmo or your PayPal account which
is pretty sickening if you ask me all
you have to do is go to perfect
snacks.com toast to get a free perfect
bar today that's perfect snacks.com
toasty at a free perfect bar today happy
snacking
today's episode is also brought to you
by Queen Charlotte a Bridgerton story so
a new show on Netflix that's centered on
Queen Charlotte's rise to prominence and
power this Bridgerton verse prequel
tells the story of how the young Queen's
marriage to King George sparked for the
great love story and a societal shift
creating the world of the ton inherited
by the characters in Bridgeton so I love
this show it's now streaming on Netflix
and it's basically just a prequel to
Bridgerton but it tells you all about
Queen Charlotte who we know and love
from the show and what's so great is
that it's a story about how young
Charlotte come to came to be who she is
but it also has young Agatha Danbury
young Violet Bridgeton and we're going
to learn how these ladies came to be the
Beloved and revered characters that they
are in Bridgerton you'll learn how they
found their place in power all while
navigating their personal passions and
politics of course it's written by
Shonda Rhimes she's also the executive
producer so you know it's good and
what's great one of the things we all
love about Bridgerton it's very steamy
and I can confirm the chemistry between
young Queen Charlotte and her young King
George is very steamy it's giving smut
the series has all the elements of
Bridgerton that you know and love like
sex romance Scandal and of course the
ton so it's the love story to inspire
all love stories the kind of love that
the entire ton aspires to for themselves
it's the myth that has set everything so
it is now streaming on Netflix it is
only available on Netflix and you can
watch it now you guys are gonna love it
I love it if you love Bridgerton if you
love sexy steamy romance if you love
something you know with beautiful women
and beautiful gowns and beautiful makeup
and beautiful wigs this show is for you
the actress who plays young Queen
Charlotte is so pretty and she's so
talented I've been loving it and I think
you guys are going to love it too so
enjoy Queen Charlotte a Bridgerton story
watch now only on Netflix
thanks turdy luya I am a happy snacker
yeah you are our fifth and final story
is a little update in this streaming
Wars because Hulu and Disney plus
content will be combined into one app
which makes sense as they're both owned
by Disney Disney will be combining Hulu
content with Disney plus content into
one app in the US CEO Bob Iger announced
on Wednesday the company will begin to
roll out the new app by the end of the
calendar year for now this option will
only be available to Consumers who have
subscribed to both services so they'll
continue to offer Disney Plus Hulu and
ESPN plus as Standalone options this is
a logistical progression of their DTC
offerings that will provide greater
opportunities for advertisers blah blah
blah said Bob Iger I want to know what
it's going to be called
oh okay we could come up with names I
just want to say I'm actually surprised
that I took them this long I've always
found it very confusing like knowing
that Disney owns a million things like
Hulu like ESPN like why did all just
don't have like one kind of like peacock
like how everything on Bravo NBC why
they don't just have like one kind of
this is a little bigger than NBC much
bigger because it's like ABC it would be
like peacock plus Netflix like yeah so I
understand everyone had to come together
also like Disney owns a stake of Hulu
but not all of Hulu Comcast also owns
some of them
it's very confusing
um but
I oh I totally thought it was just like
a Disney Company
no no interesting yeah there's some
shares that are being so I wonder why
Comcast is okay with like Disney taking
Hulu you know
is kind of confusing like I feel like it
can't just be called Disney plus with
like Hulu there because Hulu's its own
brand you know oh yeah and they have
like original content right and people
are attached to Hulu yeah so I feel like
they need a new name but they're not
going to have like another parent
company when they have all of these
really strong brands
yeah well what is the parent company
technically Disney
yeah I guess like ESPN going in Disney
would kind of make sense I think like a
lot of people know that Disney owns ESPN
but Hulu going under the umbrella of
Disney like wouldn't be easy for people
to digest because we're like freaks who
know everything about like the streaming
landscape the streaming Wars but most
people don't
yeah I feel like what if they get have
it be an app it's called like Walt Walt
Max
I don't hate it I don't love it
Walt Max yeah like maybe that's not it
or what if it's like Walt plus
again it's like not really rolling off
the tongue for me okay
if you guys have a good call as to what
this app should be called like feel free
to drop a comment I'm I imagine they're
struggling because you can't get a more
known brand name than Disney so like to
take the Disney out of Disney like what
are you gonna replace it with that's
even gonna come close
not only that but these are like three
really recognizable stand-alone Brands
ESPN Hulu like that's what you know
Brands can only dream of like oh like
Hulu has become almost a verb you know
so to give that up is kind of weird and
I don't know what a better name would be
rebranding is the for like these big ass
companies not even that this is a
Rebrand but it really is so difficult
yeah unless they just called it like
Plus
you know kind of like how HBO Max is
Maximilian
oh that's true
what they should just call it Igor Plus
yeah but this is so transient there like
last year he was out this week he's in
speaking of they should call it Miska
Muska Plus
what about
hot dog hot diggity dog Plus or just
like diggity dog
love that what about no I literally have
it Oh Toodles Plus
love
oh
[Music]
speaking of CEOs I attempted to watch I
have two episodes behind us of
succession so I attempted to watch it on
the flight it made the flight feel like
15 hours I didn't even get through one
whole episode they go to LA to like
check on their movie studio or whatever
it's so
abysmal like it's horrible abysmal
unwatchable actually I can't believe
there are people who sit around and
watch the episodes and say like this is
the best show on television in the last
10 years people and then they finished
the episode and they're like give them
all the Emmys
no like don't no don't
give the give the Emmy to Molly Shannon
for her work in the other two give the
work give the Emmy to Ken Todd can you
believe Raquel spent the noise Tom
Sandoval
yeah
right
sorry I didn't mean to get you off track
to I was just like to complain about
success yeah you didn't mean to like get
off track from our brainstorm because
that's what we were doing and I didn't
know that Bob is listen Bob's daughter
is listening like hoping that we
actually come up with the name yeah I
did like kind of derail their brainstorm
because I genuinely cannot think of one
decent idea like this is so hard it's
really hard
unless they just like come up with a new
word which is what a lot of times people
try and do but I don't think that really
ever Works what if it was like dooloo
okay it's honestly not bad
his knee
no like dulu plus Disney Hulu and ESPN
plus his knee Plus
his knee her knee
my name there knee yeah
they're neon friends
no it's not cutting a Jacks I'm sorry
it's not good
okay well there's no such thing as a bad
idea as long as like we're all
contributing and putting ourselves out
there
right and I'm really not contributing I
told you I cannot think of one thing to
name this this app you could always go
brass and stress Plus
oh
wait
I like it strong
I don't know because
um I like I like it
so a couple of free bad ideas take them
or leave them that's just kind of like
what we do here you know yeah that's a
lot of what we do
um so I'm headed to the ACM smarter is
anybody you like want me to stay on the
carpet and like chat to should I bring
up bring up or you should
do you want me to bring up to Luke Combs
like his pronoun like Saga that he works
in the market as a checkout girl
because I'll do it if the vibe is right
yeah
like is that something you want me to
wait for you like the next year no I
don't know when I'm gonna see Luke again
and by then I'll have like you know new
things to obsess over but I just wonder
is it like every time you sing it it's
like rats that bothers me or I do what
do you even know no so I actually think
when you're like an artist who covers
famous songs a new thing people do is
like they change the pronouns to make it
accurate for them like if it's a song
from a girl's perspective they just
change it to like the boy pronouns and
part of me actually really respects that
he just left the perfect song like it's
a perfect song for a reason like people
have loved this song for like 30 years
so part of me actually really respects
that he didn't like change it for his
own image you know yeah he's just like
the manliest man no it's crazy that he
has like fox in the hen house and then
he calls himself a girl like it's weird
I get it
and I was wrong I thought that he
actually did change the lyric so you
work in the market as a checkout like
talking to the girl but I was wrong
which I always am which should be a
shock to know about it
so yeah if the Vibes are good and you
feel like he would be open to talking
about it then yeah ask him for sure
yeah I'm I mean I'm hoping me and Margo
get a few minutes with him he's so busy
he's one of the most nominated people to
be here tomorrow night do you also see
Morgan Wallen posted on his story today
like just like like something being like
people really talking about the side of
their necks I kind of felt like he was
talking about us but our company
believed him
and I'm sorry for him to assume like
nobody's gonna question this like sorry
given his track record like we just
wanted to do our due diligence yeah so
maybe we came to the conclusion
well I don't like maybe you could ask
him who's talking out of the side of
their decks
you know what he'll be like you [__]
it's literally you shut the [__] up stop
talking about me on your podcast that's
literally what he's gonna say
just be like but we believed you we just
need to get we need to talk it through
we're talkers that's why we have a
podcast Morgan yeah
who else is going to be there
um
well I actually Dolly Parton I'm hoping
to get up close to Dolly because have
you seen this conspiracy theory about
her hands no
okay and I thought it was crazy but like
now when I see pictures I'm like oh she
wears prosthetic she wears like gloves
that are like prosthetic hands like
they're made out of like skin like
technology so she like moved her fingers
but like it's not her skin
I believe I thought it was interesting
I think that's smart
and Garth Brooks her at Dolly and Garth
are hosting Dolly and Garth are hosting
hmm so my question for Dolly would be
did you get a chance to listen to the
redheads episode about run Rose run and
what did you think about the girl's
assessment
yeah I definitely think if I bring up
run Rose run like nobody else on the
carpet is bringing up the random book
she co-authored with James Patterson
right I feel like that's a good way to
break the ice and to be different not
like other interviewers yeah and I think
they are making it into like a movie or
something so maybe just like throw away
around some casting ideas are you gonna
do an original song already did she
wrote a whole album for the book but
yeah cool cool cool cool I'm so glad I
didn't ask and then for Garth Brooks
I would say
have you heard of girth Brooks
no what I would say is how does it feel
to have your song like you have so many
accomplishments but it would argue your
biggest one is your song being covered
in Country Strong what did that movie
mean to you
yeah that's a good one I think that's
like a pretty good place to start
so I think you're all have what you need
yeah no my research here is done
I'm excited to watch you on the Amazon
fashion Snapchat yes Jax thanks so much
for recording with me tonight I know
you're like a busy mom and I'm just like
an animal who doesn't plan things and I
really appreciate you no you plan this
totally fine it's literally fine I just
happen to be more tired than usual and
it's fine
so it's fine it's totally fine we're
good
thank you guys so much scared of me
the millennial Morning Show where we
deliver the pacified stories you need to
know everybody through Friday and
YouTube so if you're watching this on
YouTube please don't forget to
subscribing give this video a thumbs up
we're also available podcast anywhere
podcasting events on Spotify Channel
Studio public radio hi everybody
talent that we are hope you guys have a
great day great weekend there's no show
Friday and we'll see you back in studio
on Monday bye love you bye